[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN LIPPERT: Thanks a lot,
everyone, for joining us today.
So I'm going to be joined
by Venky Iyer here.
My name is Ryan Lippert.
And what we'll be
talking about today
is just the
advantage of managed.
And when we talk
about that, we're
really talking about Hadoop and
migrating that from AWS to GCP.
Now, before I turn
things over to Venky,
he's the real star
of the show here,
what I'm going to do is just
quickly walk through Dataproc
in general and what we
see as our advantages.
But really, that's going to
be hit home a lot better,
I think, by Venky whenever
he gets up and tells
his own customer
story about things.
So let's talk about Dataproc
and just what is it,
and then why do we think
that's important from a Google
perspective.
So I think that the best
place to start there
if you're going to
talk about Dataproc
is to talk about traditional
Spark and Hadoop clusters,
and the way that we think
about those, and the way
that those actually go into
implementation and operation.
So with the traditional cluster,
what you end up having is,
within your cluster, you
have your data technology,
your governance.
You have security in there.
And then that lies on top of
operations and management.
Now, the issue with those
traditional Spark and Hadoop
clusters is that they're
not really integrated
with other tools.
They've got to be
shared between many.
And it's really difficult
to make those changes.
And those changes end
up creating something
that we like to call the
de-value chain of big data,
to some extent.
And so this is probably
familiar to anyone
who's provisioned Hadoop
clusters on-premises one
way or the other.
But you've got to
obtain servers first.
From there, you have
to configure servers.
After that, you're installing
the open source software.
Then you're configuring
that software.
From there, you're
optimizing it.
Then you need to debug it.
And then you can
finally get to the point
where you're ready to
start to process data.
And so that's a long cycle.
And anytime that you want to
start that cycle over again
to scale, you've got
to go through each one
of those individual steps.
Likewise, if you get
to the end of things
and you say, hey,
actually, what we
need to do is a
reconfiguration here,
you're looking at
restarting that halfway
through the process.
And so what you end up
with is a lot of lost time.
And then that lost time is
also sunk costs that end up
going in, to getting to a
point where, really, what you
want to up doing is processing
data at the end of the day.
And so if we can get closer
to that processing data
piece of things, that's
going to be really
what our customers are
actually looking for.
So the cycle that we just
showed on that last slide,
it usually leads to pain.
So the first kind of
pain is scaling pain.
So anytime that you need
to add new capacity in,
you end up with a
lag between when
your needs come on and then
when you can actually get that
out and into production.
And that's because there's
just so much time is required
to be able to actually
get the truck rollout
and make that happen.
There's also an issue from an
utilization pain perspective.
So the way that you usually see
it is you've got your cluster.
It's up and running.
It's taking in data at
the time that it needs to.
Its processing data
as it needs to.
But then there are big
inactive times as well.
And so you're still paying
for that inactive time,
particularly if it's not
a managed type solution.
And then what that
leads to is cost pain.
And in cost pain,
what you'd see is
you're still reducing your
costs as you move to Hadoop over
legacy technologies.
But what you're doing
is, because you've over
provisioned, and because
you've got inactive clusters,
your cost is always going to
be more than what it actually
should be if you could
actually get to a point
where you're only
using what you need.
And so that's why we
think that, really,
the cluster and the platform
should work together.
And that's what we've
tried to build here.
And so when we think
about that, the stuff
that you'd rather not
care about every time,
that's the governance, the
security, the operations
and management.
Those are all very
important things
when it comes to
running a cluster,
but it's not really
what you care about.
And that's the data technology
that you're running in it.
You really want to
get to the point
where you're looking
at your analytics,
you're looking at the
solutions, and you're
looking at the data
processing, and being
able to focus on that
as opposed to everything
else within your stack.
And so that's why we've
developed Cloud Dataproc.
And that's where we think
that our solution's pretty
differentiated from what you'd
see out there in the market
more broadly.
So Cloud Dataproc is just--
it's fast, it's easy to use,
it's low cost,
it's fully managed,
and it's all on Google
Cloud Platform, which
means that it's integrated
with the other tools
that we have within
our platform as well.
And so that really
allows you to get
up and moving a lot
faster than you would
be able to if you were trying
to run this on your own,
whether in a cloud and
just doing your self-hosted
or on-premises.
And so our vision,
as I mentioned, fast.
So let's make sure that it
takes seconds to spin things
up, not minutes, not weeks,
definitely not months,
as it can sometimes be.
We want things to
be easy as well.
So be an expert with
your data, but not
necessarily the infrastructure.
Let's focus on what we're
doing from a data perspective.
And then let's make
it so that you only
pay for what you're using,
as opposed to everything
that you've got static that
could be in your stack that's
not actually working on things.
And so when we actually
look, particularly
at that last point from
a cost perspective,
we've had some analysts come
out with some studies that
say that when you look at Cloud
Dataproc, particularly relative
to on-premises, it's 57%
less expensive than that.
And then even when
you look at EMR,
it's going to be
32% less expensive.
So the way that that
ends up happening
is as we move from
on-premises to just doing it
on Compute Engine, or
potentially in another cloud,
then all the way across
to Cloud Dataproc, what
you see is that on-premises,
you're self-managed
for everything, from code down
to the creation and deployment.
And then as you start to
move from left to right
on the screen, from a
Compute Engine perspective,
Google starts to take over
things like connectivity,
deployment, and creation.
But when you get
towards Cloud Dataproc,
you can see that the only thing
that the customers and users
end up being responsible for
is really getting to a point
where they're putting
in their custom code.
And then everything
else along the way
is taken care of for you.
And so when we
generally look at folks
who are starting to do
these migrations one
way or the other, if it's a lift
and shift from another cloud,
if it's even a lift and
shift within Google,
from self-hosted to
running Dataproc,
or particularly if it's
on-prem to into the cloud,
there's a set of six
common principles
that we would typically
look at and say, hey,
here's what you should
be thinking about.
The first is separating
compute and storage.
As you move into Dataproc,
the ability to do that
is going to allow you to
move a lot more efficiently.
Use ephemeral and
long-lived clusters.
So start to try to classify
them in one way or the other.
If you have a cluster that
always needs to stay on,
make sure that you've
got the data that
needs to be processed
in that cluster.
And then the ones that you can
spin up and spin down quickly,
separate those out.
You also want to right size the
clusters per use case as well.
So understand what
your use case is
and spin up clusters that
makes sense for that.
This create and
delete clusters often
goes very well
with the ephemeral
and long-lived clusters.
There's no need to keep
those up and running
if you can spin them down.
And then with a 60 to
90 second spin up time
for those clusters,
you can bring them
back anytime that you need to.
Replacing HDFS
with Cloud Storage.
And then finally, using
Dataproc jobs through the APIs
that we offer.
So that's a good
Google overview,
but I think what
everyone's really here
for is to hear more from a
customer, to hear about how
this actually goes,
potentially warts
and all, whenever it looks
like a lift and shift here.
So with that, I'd like
to introduce Venky.
Venky is a software
engineer from Thumbtack.
So everyone give a good
hand to Venky here.
[APPLAUSE]
VENKY IYER: Thanks, Ryan.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Venky.
I'm a software
engineer at Thumbtack.
In the fall of 2016, we decided
to move our self-hosted Hadoop
setup, data infrastructure
setup, from AWS
to managed services
on Google Cloud.
And today I'm here to
tell you that story.
But before I begin, let
me offer you a quick intro
on what is Thumbtack.
In the world around us, it
would seem that capitalism
exists to make people lazier.
And we do our bit by trying
to solve this problem.
Why is it so hard to hire
a plumber or a gardener
or a photographer?
You can buy anything
you want with one click.
You can book travel around the
world in a matter of minutes.
But when you want to hire
a piano tutor for your kid,
you are forced to
use the analog world.
Maybe talk to somebody.
Look up Yelp or Yellow Pages
and try and make a few calls
and see what works out.
Thumbtack is an
online marketplace
that connects customers
to professionals
who match their specific job
requirements, their schedule,
and their budget.
And Thumbtack is
also a platform that
enables professionals
and small business
owners to focus on
what they do best,
to focus on their core trade.
And Thumbtack works on their
behalf to acquire customers
with high intent for them.
And like any other
internet company,
internet business
in today's age,
we are highly reliant on data.
We need data for
core broad features,
like matching that I just
talked about for paid customer
acquisition through
SEM channels.
We need timely and reliable data
to inform our top line metrics,
like customer
growth and revenue.
We need data for
analyzing our experiments.
We need data to train our
machine learning models.
I'm sure a lot of you will
find this all too familiar.
So let's begin this story of
how we at Thumbtack attempted
to solve for these requirements.
And we begin with a
state we were in a little
more than three years ago--
the V0 infrastructure,
or rather the lack of it.
So we had this PHP
website, and we
used to run a daemon
that would collect events
from those website
servers, which
we would dump it into
MongoDB, for whatever reason.
We had a bunch of Python scripts
that would read those events,
do some data aggregation,
and do an in-place update,
again, for whatever reason.
And creating this
infrastructure was very slow.
We could analyze only
one experiment at a time.
And if, by chance, you
wanted to find insights
into relational
data, you kind of
go into a completely different
world of a looker instance,
which was hooked on
to a live PG replica.
So very fragile,
very slow, not very
feature rich, and
yet somehow comprised
of complex and convoluted code.
So this was clearly
a problem statement
that we had to attempt to solve.
And that began with our first
generation of infrastructure.
So we set up Cloudera Hadoop on
a bunch of AWS EC2 instances.
We set up Spark on it.
We converted all
our data processing
from like random Python
scripts, or whatever,
to Scala, essentially
Spark jobs.
We wrote all the data
output in Parquet format.
We configured Cloudera
impala as a SQL engine
on top of that Parquet data.
And we used a visualization
tool called Mode and hooked it
on to the Cloudera Impala
so that our analysts can now
create fancy dashboards.
This infrastructure was
the first generation
that powered our experiment
visualization tool
that we called Prospect.
It also powered our first
ML Prediction API serving,
which we called Matchbox.
And we set up Airflow.
We used Airflow to
orchestrate all these jobs,
to define the
schedules, to define
the dependencies between jobs,
on which should run after what.
Overall, a huge step up
from where we were before,
but not without its problems.
The first of which was
we were continuously
playing musical chairs
with the capacity, right?
This is where the de-value
chain that Ryan talked
about kind of commences for us.
Jobs would step on each other.
Invariably, what would happen is
a lot of scheduled Mode reports
would be scheduled to
run at 7:00 AM or 8:00 AM
so that people get fresh data
when they come to the office.
And they would
overload the cluster.
Very frequently, we would field
queries like, hey, my dashboard
looks off.
Is it a data problem,
or did we really
tank our revenue yesterday?
So we clearly needed
to do something
about the reliability
of data there.
And ironically, in
spite of all that,
during midday, if nobody's
running any ad hoc query's,
then data cluster was idle.
So there was very
little elasticity
in our infrastructure
that we had set up.
Data was replicated
within the HDFS.
It maintains multiple
copies, but that was it.
So we had this slight
durability risk as well.
And what it meant as
a team for us is this
was a huge time sink in terms
of operational workload.
For engineers from
Google and Facebook
and the like to appreciate
this a bit more,
I would like to
tell that this was
a team of six engineers
responsible for everything,
from setting up the
clusters to setting up
Hadoop and Spark on top of it
to actually writing the data
infrastructure that
we really needed.
So this was a huge time sink.
So we had to kind of--
we were at a point
where we had to start
thinking forward on how do we
solve these problems.
And these were our alternatives.
The most obvious one
was to double down
on the same path, which would
have inevitably translated
into separating out our
compute and analysis clusters.
Which would have meant
investing in some cluster
management tools that would
help us with capacity planning.
Maybe it would automate
some operational tasks.
But to summarize what
this would have meant
is we would have had to hire
our way out of that thing.
And for companies
like ours, that thing
is a lot easier said than done.
So that was when
we started thinking
about managed solutions.
And these are the
two options that we
got to compare head on head.
So Dataproc and BigQuery
offerings on Google,
and EMR and RedShift
offering on AWS.
So comparing Dataproc
and EMR, EMR at the time
took about 30 minutes
to spin up a cluster.
It has improved
now a little bit,
but again, we thought that
really doesn't get us out
of this capacity
planning thing, right?
We would still have to spin
up clusters and figure out
how many jobs, or which
jobs can be run on this one.
Whereas Google
Dataproc can help us
think in terms of
job scope clusters.
So I'll get into the details
of that in a little bit.
And comparing
BigQuery and RedShift,
we definitely liked
BigQuery more, because, A,
it was truly serverless.
It supported nested data
types, which we used a lot of.
And it was an added advantage
that it worked on Google Sheets
as a federated data
source, which would please
a lot of people in the company.
So it was definitely advantage
Google at this point.
And this is the
story that led us
to the decision point of where
we decided to take the plunge.
So in the next section, I
want to talk about how do we
get on from there, right?
Decisions like this
are seldom unanimous.
There are counterpoints
within and outside the team.
And even for us
who were in favor,
we had to acknowledge
our failability here.
We had to acknowledge,
is this the right part?
Or if it is, how do I prove it?
So we started
thinking about, how
do we get some initial
success pointers?
How do we say that we
are on the right track?
So for that, what we
did is we partnered
with our analytics
team to identify
some of the important
datasets, and just
copied them over to BigQuery.
And then the Mode
visualization tool
that I talked about, we pointed
that to BigQuery instead.
So there was some work
involved in changing the SQL
from the Impala SQL dialect
to BigQuery's standard SQL
dialect.
There were some minor changes.
You had to handle the
timestamp fields differently,
and so on and so forth.
So it took some kind
of documentation
and some education part of it.
But overall, not
such a daunting task.
And in order to keep
that data fresh,
what we did was we leveraged
our Airflow infrastructure
and inserted a
small cross-copy job
at the end of our data pipeline.
So we had this
bunch of processing
that would end up
producing a Parquet output.
And then we had
one downstream job
that would read
this Parquet file,
convert that into Airflow,
dump that into GCS,
an update that to BigQuery.
So that data in
BigQuery remains fresh,
while still, all the
processing is on AWS.
So this gave us two benefits.
In hindsight, I
think this turned out
to be a really good
call, A, because analysts
who were the number one
customers of this data
infrastructure gave a thumbs up.
I mean, their queries, they
found a quick turnaround
time from BigQuery.
The failure and timeout rate
was markedly a lot lower
than before.
So it was an immediate
win for them.
So that was good.
And this gave us a
good migration path.
So now we could
think about migration
without interrupting any
of the business workflows,
interrupting any of
the other team's plans.
Your dashboards will still work.
The data is all still there.
While in the background,
one data pipeline at a time,
we can take and move
it from AWS to Google.
So with that headwind,
we really doubled down
and started building
some of the other pieces
on top of Google Cloud
that really enabled us
to leverage this
infrastructure effectively.
And now I'll talk a little bit
more about job scoped clusters.
This is an entire
paradigm shift.
Now, instead of
thinking of setting up
a cluster with this many
CPUs and this much memory,
and figuring out how many
jobs can run on this cluster,
now we could think about,
hey, I have this job.
What resources
does this job need?
Since a cluster can be spun
up in like 60 seconds, or 90
seconds, that job can
go ahead and spin up
the cluster it needs
and then just run,
without any interference
from any other job.
It just felt like
good parenting, right.
Job one you run in cluster one.
Job two you run in cluster two.
No fighting.
And it worked.
And some of the other
things that we discovered
while we were setting
up our info on Google
was we realized that
for downstream jobs,
it was much more performant
and cost effective
to read it from GCS
rather than BigQuery.
So when you dump data into
BigQuery, you stage that in GCS
anyway, because that's
how the BQ load works.
We just made sure that we gave
that part a formal convention,
so that we can address
our data on GCS as well.
And downstream Spark jobs
could just read data from GCS.
We leveraged the audit logs
from both BigQuery and Dataproc,
fed it back into BigQuery so
that we can query it and clear
dashboards on it.
And we used that
to gain insights
into our usage and cost of how
we are using this platform.
And finally, we used the
fine-grained data access
and auth management in BigQuery
to really share data search
to a wide range of
teams, including
the contractors as well.
But the migration was not
without its challenges, right?
So the first two
I called out here
are required non-trivial
amount of code refactoring.
Now, we are dealing
with clusters
that we spin up and down.
So HDFS is in
ephemeral storage now.
So we really had to move
all our data storage
into an object like
Google Cloud Storage.
At the time, BigQuery
did not support Parquet,
so we had to convert
everything into Avro.
And we got into some gnarly
data type conversion issues.
But yeah, that
needed to be solved.
A couple of runtime challenges--
one was a difference
in performance characteristics.
So Dataproc tries to fit two
Spark executors per worker.
And we realized that--
and it tries to allocate
roughly 50% of resources
to each of those executors.
And we realized that if we
tune a memory a little bit,
like heap memory or
out of heap memory,
Dataproc would
sometimes only schedule
one executor on one worker.
And we would be at a loss of
we are throwing like this--
we have spun up this
24-node cluster,
but still it takes
twice as long.
I mean, why?
And then we realized it's
only using half the cluster.
So that took some Sherlock work
and investigation type thing.
And the other thing was
cross-cloud networking.
Now we are moving
data back and forth,
so we had to set up
some networking gear.
We had to set up the auth
keys that can be shared
and rotated in a good way.
And all these are from
a technical perspective.
And from a management and
organizational perspective,
what it meant is the
time spent on migration
is a time not spent
on the feature request
that all other teams have.
So this is something that
we just asked the company
to take us up on good faith,
and were grateful for them
for their patience.
But we did overcome it.
And we did end up
having, in today's date,
we are leveraging
Google to a good effect.
We have compounded the
number of jobs and queries
we are running.
We create and destroy more
than 700 clusters per day.
We run more than
12,000 queries a day.
We added streaming
ETL capabilities.
We used Deployment Manager to
have this entire configuration
on GCP as code.
So all in all, I think we
did overcome all of that
to come to a very
good state here.
And we also used the Google's
organization and projects
hierarchy to create
multiple projects
and to control data visibility.
And also, to have a
per department billing,
so to speak, so we
could figure out where
our expenses are coming from.
Yeah, talk about this?
Right.
So that's kind of
the story of how
we came to a decision point,
why we decided on GCP,
and how we migrated to GCP.
And in this last
section of this talk,
I want to just share the
thoughts as we reflect upon,
so what do we make
of all that things?
How did this project go for us?
Starting with this
question that,
did we truly achieve what
we set out to achieve?
And several things come to mind.
I mean, we currently
run, like I said,
a lot more queries,
a lot more jobs,
a lot more capabilities on
the data infrastructure.
As well as we are
now, as a team,
taking on more problems, even
outside of the data scope.
So if I have to condense
all that into one word,
that's time.
We gained time.
For a limited set of
engineers, we really
figured out that we could save
time and spend somewhere else
wisely.
And one other thing
that I think about
that we could not have
gained without this migration
is to truly democratize data.
The scale of BigQuery, the
scale and the flexibility
with creating both normal
and materialized views
and have different auth
scopes for each one of them
has really helped us to shared
datasets with almost all
of the organizations, all the
departments within the company.
And everybody across the
company is leveraging that data.
So that's a huge win for us.
So those are the
good aspects of it.
So there is also one more way
to think about all these things
as there are plenty of
risks along the way.
So how do we think we
did with the risks?
Starting with planning fallacy.
So planning fallacy is
when you are making a plan,
you're super optimistic.
I'll do this in
like three months.
But you overshoot it, right?
And we did fell for this.
We started like we
should be able to do
this within six months, from
MVP to all the way to the end.
But we did bleed into the
third quarter of the migration.
But we did put our heads
down and complete it.
The other estimate that
we overshot by a lot
is we thought we would
spend less on Google.
But that did not
turn out to be true.
But that's OK, because
now we are actually
spending more because we are
using that data a lot more.
We are running a lot more jobs.
We are running a
lot more queries.
And that's where
the cost comes from.
The second risk I think about
is the sunk cost fallacy.
Sometimes these migrations keep
going on for months and months.
And somewhere along the halfway
through, you think about, hey,
I've come this far.
And that becomes the
only reason for just kind
of keep going forward.
It happens when you don't
have an option to go back,
or going back becomes
really expensive, right?
And this is an item where
I think we did really well.
A, because we always had
a path of going back.
We didn't dismantle
our AWS infrastructure
until we were completely here.
So if we had hit a roadblock,
if we, at any point of time,
thought that, hey, this
is not working out,
we had other alternatives.
And one other thing
that helped us is we
had scoped in the
beginning that we are only
going to move our
data infrastructure
and nothing more.
And that scope
remained unaltered
throughout this project.
And that was, again, one
other good thing in hindsight.
So these two are
more with respect
to the migration,
migration related risks.
The third risk I
want to talk about
is more of an existential
risk when you operate
in a multi-cloud environment.
So Conway's law, I don't know
if you've heard about it.
It states that organizations
will produce designs
that will have the communication
structures that they
have within the organization.
What it translates to in
reality is if your one team is
responsible for your
Google infrastructure,
if the some second team is
a responsible for your AWS
infrastructure, when you
think about solutions,
can you truly think about one
single base data center infra?
Or otherwise, I mean,
if the teams work well,
you can do that.
If the teams don't
work well together,
you would have one solution
here and one solution here
that would not talk
to each other, right?
So like I said, this
is an existential risk.
You're completely not
out of the woods yet.
But the good thing
is just being aware
of it is a very good step.
And this is something that we
have to be mindful of from here
on.
This never ends.
So that's was a brief
scorecard on how we did.
So now I'll take
a liberty to give
a scorecard on how Google did.
Overall, I think the uptime
has been pretty solid.
The scale-- that scale and load
that we threw at Google, Google
has handled, no big deal.
Their support teams have
been pretty responsive,
for both low priority issues as
well as high priority issues.
These were the good parts.
But that does not mean that
there were no issues at all.
They're also a software company.
They also rely on software.
Things go wrong.
Some of the things I wanted to
highlight was, like last year,
we had a couple of
BigQuery related incidents.
Essentially, they
were breaking changes.
They were not backward
compatible changes
at Google's end that kind of
brought our data processing
to a grinding halt.
One of these was, for example,
the nullability of Avro fields
and nullability of
BigQuery fields.
The requirements were made
strict that they should match,
which wasn't the case before.
And we were freely
using strict fields
and mapping them to
nullable fields in BigQuery,
so that broke everything.
The other thing was, again, some
charting changes that we had
to set a particular variable.
And more recently, we had a
bunch of issues with Dataproc.
There was one where the GC
images weren't available.
There were a couple in June.
Again, one related
to some networking
and one of something
else in the backend.
And both of these were,
unfortunately, kind
of impacted the entire region.
So maybe that's one CBB.
That's a term that
we use in Thumbtack
called Could Be Better.
So one Could Be Better
that I would call out
is probably have a rollout
plan that, even if it goes bad,
does not impact
the entire region.
Maybe just a few
[INAUDIBLE] within a region.
But it did force us
to rethink, and we
were able to
leverage our Airflow
infrastructure to move
from a single region
to be multi-region.
And since the BigQuery
and the GCS layer
were multi-region anyway,
it was easy for us to do so.
And another Could Be Better
that I would call out is,
for example, that April issue
had an amazing postmortem,
but the June issue didn't.
So it's all a great
learning experience
to learn about what went wrong.
We can understand more about
how everything works internally.
And sometimes it can
get to action items
for us, that if
we could do this,
we could protect ourselves
a little bit more.
But overall, I think
it's a great time
to be out there and building
products on these cloud
platforms, that you
don't have to think
about so many complex and
sophisticated infrastructure
things.
Google, given its
scale with Search,
has solved these problems.
Their infrastructure works
from mind-boggling scale
and complexity.
And it's great that
they are making
it available for
other people to use it
to their cloud infrastructure.
I mean, which other
company in this world
can think of building
a spanner, for example?
But as users of it,
it still takes work.
It still takes a lot
of thought on how
do you want to go about it.
It still takes dedication.
It still takes coming
up with a cohesive plan
and making tradeoffs.
So with that, I'll
conclude my talk.
Thank you very
much for listening.
And if you have any
questions, I can take that.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LIPPERT: So
Venky, thanks a lot.
That was a terrific
presentation.
I think that everyone
here has enjoyed it.
Because I've got
this special mic,
I'll kick off with a few
questions just to start.
One of the first
things I thought
the crowd might be
interested in hearing about
is, you talked a lot
about multi-cloud there.
Can you talk a little
bit about the egress cost
there, and what that's
been like for Thumbtack?
VENKY IYER: Right.
So we're kind of exporting
a lot of data out of AWS,
so we're mainly talking
about egress costs in AWS.
It's not been that high, in
the sense that, for example,
our Sqoop jobs still run.
Every single time they run,
they take the entire database
snapshot.
There are some kind of
nice to have optimizations.
We could have
streaming replication
into Google, which would
reduce the egress costs.
But overall, those
figures are not that high
that we have to drop everything
and fix that thing right now.
Like I said, again,
this goes in terms
of how we think about our time.
We prioritize
products and projects
that are important to our
company's top line first.
But all in all, I
think that egress costs
are pretty much under
control and manageable.
RYAN LIPPERT:
That's great, Venky.
And so I think
another thing you've
talked a lot about where you've
been and where you've come to.
What's next for
you at Thumbtack?
What are you thinking about
in terms of the new use cases
you're going after, or what's
next for your infrastructure
there, as you think about data
and analytics in particular?
VENKY IYER: Right.
So having the robust
infrastructure
like this for base
data processing really
becomes the
foundation on which we
can build some more
sophisticated and complex
processing.
We are now trying
to invest a lot
into our machine
learning infrastructure
using Tensorflow.
Currently we are using
Tensorflow serving on AWS,
but we would like to
evaluate Cloud ML.
As well as we are evaluating
Dataflow to create the feature
extraction pipelines that we
could run in both streaming
and batch modes.
So those are some of
the things that are
coming up and in the pipeline.
RYAN LIPPERT: That sounds great.
And if I might, just one more
question for you before let's
open it up to the audience.
When you think about what we can
do from a Google perspective,
or what other services that
we could potentially offer,
is there anything in
our stack that you'd
like to see that maybe
you're not currently seeing,
that we could be working on?
VENKY IYER: Yeah, so I
think one of the things
that I missed on
Google infrastructure
while setting up everything was
having a pub/sub system that
supported some level
of partial ordering.
I'm a huge fan of the Kafka
paradigm of messaging, Kafka
or Apache Pulsar.
Both have some partial ordering,
so that enables, for example,
you to have database streams
into your pub/sub system.
Google Pub/Sub has taken
a different philosophy
for scalability.
They're updated off
the ordering part.
That's because the Google
Dataflow's stream processing
pipeline is very feature rich.
It can do some even time
windowing and reorder there.
But if you are not
really using that,
we would really want to
see some heavy lifting done
on the pub/sub side.
I think that would be
very useful for us.
And I've recently
learned that, I think,
Confluent and Google
are partnering
to set up managed Kafka on GCP.
So that's something we would
check it out and see what
we can build on top of that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]